with the emergence of benny
right over the last two years then he
went from being like
you know like y'all's homie who would
come along and rap
kind of like what like rick ricky hyde
is now that's our cousin
right shout out to rick um and now he's
emerging as like a star in his own right
um does that like
just like i wonder between all three of
y'all man
because gunn put out pray for paris
which is a classic
right you know you guys have all had
your share of timeless music how is the
competition within the crew
like is it like yo fam i i you know i
got you on that [ __ ]
yeah honestly like tito's back i got
y'all on that [ __ ]
yeah honestly yeah it really ain't no
like
um like we're not competing like we
it's not on the outside i'm sure deep
inside [ __ ] like i'm about to kill i
gotta kill benny on this
right right right right my body i know
conway gonna come about to
kill this [ __ ] i'm sure inside it's a
competitive you know i mean uh um fun
competition fun
yeah no friendly all day yeah of course
but um family
we really champion each other and just
live like we just like salute like yeah
no that [ __ ]
crazy you know what i mean i think
that's what's unique about charles is
like even if you
i mean you know like i remember the
first time i watched the show
documentary when i was a kid and i saw
that wu
tang didn't get along like method man
and you god were fighting on the
documentary and i was like wait what
that's why i feel like we owe res a
little more praise so being able to put
when i watch that [ __ ] like
[ __ ] shooting on each other and i'll
cover [ __ ] like residue is able to move
forward nine
dudes all that nice and give us the
illegitimate
we are uh a debt of gratitude
that's facts but i feel like that's
what's unique about charlotte is like
no matter what we know when when we look
at that
at whoever's album it is there's gonna
be at least that one that's got all
three of y'all on
it and
you know the [ __ ] you you played me last
night which what
which album is the spurs record on is
that on verse three it's on from king to
a guy yeah
that [ __ ] is crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah
and
now that's one of the ones where it's
just like i said like when we all
together it's like
yeah i'm saying lebron wade and bosch
some [ __ ] like that mm-hmm and we just
and that that that
friendly competition that's burning in
the inside all of us want to be able to
have it as the flyers [ __ ] on the joint
i think
that's what makes when we do it all
together
make it best even with derringer because
dan during the competition too
like deep down the side like i can't
have a whacker [ __ ] on the album
mm-hmm i gotta come with come with some
crate and all three of them morning i
gotta kill some you know i mean
[ __ ] like that but like i said man i
think that's
you know we we just all like
[ __ ] being family play whose role so
we just love
you everything that we we do and push
each other like
when it was benny turn like you said
last two years like man you know me and
bro like nah go ahead benny like
if you look at all our freestyles and
[ __ ] like that i'll be like yo betty
let me hear you man yeah yeah i mean
give me what you got benny you know what
i mean and [ __ ] like that like
it was benny turn like let's go benny
yeah y'all
type [ __ ] so we do we we don't like that
man we ain't like i ain't
i could i ain't no sucker i ain't no
sucker like that like
i want everybody to win win eat